for days the town of solidar has been
hit by russian artillery the ukrainians
still hold it
we're one of the few to gain access to
this embattled town
we entered on foot without a military
escort
the streets are empty
a crater left behind in the middle of
the town
another in front of a residential
building
others destroyed
we just came out we were in a flat but
at night we're sleeping in the basement
i'm here because my daughter is ill can
i leave where am i to go
they take us to their basement
where we find others sheltering from the
shelling
at night at one o'clock in the morning
there may be shelling or the whole
evening or like a few days before
throughout the morning or there was such
a big bomb there was mud everywhere and
lots of fire
despite the war the destruction and the
constant bombardment some here still
support russia we've blurred this man's
face for his
russia will be here soon victory donbass
was always russian
the artillery battle begins again
when everyone
is now going into their basements
that's usually
a good indication of
the fact that something may be coming
back in
usually what happens is the ukraine's at
fire the russians are flying there'll be
some return fire this time the
ukrainians are fired
everyone seems to be going into their
basements
that's that sign
possibly
get out of here
soledad is in a strategic location
if russian forces manage to take it it
enables them to strike anything within
sight
the ukrainian forces are desperately
trying to stop them
al jazeera soledad